let's do a a good habit and a bad habit
one I need to build and one I need to
break building a good habit you kind of
want four things to happen for breaking
a bad habit you kind of want four things
to happen for building a good one you
want to make the Habit obvious so you
want the cues of your habits to be
obvious available visible easy to see
you want to make it easy so scaling it
down reducing friction and then you want
to make it satisfying more rewarding or
beneficial the more enjoyable it feels
more likely are to repeat it for
breaking a bad habit you just invert
those four so rather than making it
obvious you want to make it invisible
rather than making it attractive you
want to make it unattractive rather than
making it easy you want to make it
difficult and rather than making it
satisfying you want to make it
unsatisfying